we are restarting
our weekly
class or weekly discussion and our
journey through
the provisions for the hereafter
provisions for the great appointment
taken from the
life and the legacy and the ways and the
traditions of the best of mankind
authored by the late and esteemed
scholar
of islam shem sudden even
tonight inshallah ta'ala we would like
to
discuss the
chapter regarding how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would recite
the quran
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
would recite the quran how often
how he would actually recite it
the way that he would extend and
elongate
certain letters which is later developed
and refined into what is known as
tajweed
what is referred to as tajweed
this is all taken from the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and it is passed down from his
companions
through them to the tabernaein and
until it has arrived to us the scholars
of islam have
not only perfected and preserved by
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's will
and allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has not
only preserved the quran through the
scholars of islam
it's wording its meaning
and even its recitation the way that it
is recited
because the scholars of islam all agree
that the quran is read
in a way that is unique to it
no other book is read in the same way
that the quran is read
there are certain things that do
take on some of the features of the way
that we recite the quran
a then for example and then
we make the adhan and we use what is
called
tajweed and there are certain things
that
follow suit the evan the iklana
and so forth which are recited
in a certain and particular way but
there is no book
that is recited in the way that the
quran is recited it is recited in a very
specific and special
and unique way
the quran is
a book unlike any other obviously all of
the muslims
understand this or at least they know
this
even if when we really get down to the
details
many people are unaware of how of just
how
unique the quran really is
however the uniqueness of the quran
gives it a special place and position
amongst the muslims and especially the
scholarship of islam
for example the way that it is written
there is no other book there is no other
words which are written
in the way that the quran is written it
has its own particular type of cursive
it also has its own type of spelling
which is specific to the quran no other
book
the regular words modern arabic ancient
arabic they are not written in the same
way that
the quran is written there are certain
liberties taken and certain
rules of spelling which apply
only to the quran and this is referred
to as
and the reason that the companions
took this particular way of writing the
quran
different than the way that they write
other
things in the arabic language is because
the quran has a number of recitations
and in order for them to include these
recitations in the way that they
wrote it they spelled certain parts of
the quran in a very specific way
likewise the quran amongst the
companions
was known to be something that had to be
written
large and i know that that's kind of
strange to us today
i had read an article a few years
back
with regards to a certain islamic
magazine that was congratulating
a certain muslim individual
for writing the smallest quran
the world record of the smallest quran
tiny tiny tiny unreadable this
is something that
disliked very much and he was noted to
have scorned
other tabern and other companions for
writing the quran in small letters
he would scorn them anybody he saw
writing the quran in small
print he would scorn them and tell them
to
exalt the quran by writing it in big
clear beautiful lettering
this is another thing also
the companions the scholars of islam
they viewed the quran so majestic
and it is of course so majestic
that even things that go along with the
quran
would take on the ruling of the quran
what does that mean
so for example the binding
on the quran it is not permissible to
touch the mushaf
without udu and so the scholar
said as well the binding of the mushaf
is not permissible to touch without wudu
and even the
string that is in it the piece of ribbon
that is used as a bookmark
is not permissible to touch without wudu
as well
as part of the mushaf why because it is
something that is included and attached
to
the wording of the quran this is how
exalted
the quran is in the view of the
scholarship of islam
likewise the holders
of the must-have the wooden holders
you know that we would you find them
in a lot of massage
they they usually open up they fold open
and you can put the mustaf in it
the scholars of islam disliked as a
rahimahullah mention that the books of
hadith
be placed in these holders that these
holders be used for nothing except for
the mushaf
except for the quran and that even the
books of hadith should not be placed in
these holders
why because of the special place
and the great esteem that the scholars
of islam hold the quran
in and so tonight inshaallah ta'ala we
are going to
discuss some of the
things about the quran that were
specific to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam with regards
to how he recited it
how often how his voice was
whether he was on wudu or not etc
we have to understand that the
compilation of the quran
into one binded book
occurred in the time of abu bakr
al-sadiyah
but the entirety of the quran
was documented and was written down
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
so it's important for us to understand
that just because the
the book the quran was compiled
in the time of abu bakr and put into
order and binded into one bound
book doesn't mean that it wasn't
completely documented
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam every single verse of
the quran
was written and documented and
preserved during the lifetime of the
prophet muhammad
the only thing that occurred in the time
of abu bakr al-sadiq
is that they took those
writings that were written down
and they put them into one book
altogether and it's not this small
at that time it was a huge very big book
we move on to the time of arthur
mandevin
when he took this
one bound book that was with abu bakr
and then it was with omar
and then after the death of omar the
martyrdom of umar
it was passed on to hafsah the
wife of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and also the
daughter of
took this original book that was
compiled in the time of abu bakr
al-sadiq
and he made four copies or some scholars
mentioned
five copies some scholars mentioned six
copies
of this same book
with a group a committee of four of the
companions of the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam who were most versed
in the
quran and the way that the quran is
written
and spelled and the way that it was
compiled originally
by in the time and the era of abu bakr
al sadiq
and so
the quran as a complete book altogether
bound together this is something that
occurred in the time of abu bakr
but writing the quran documenting it
the quran being written meticulously
every verse
in order and also in the correct opinion
the order of the chapters
of the quran this all came from the
prophet muhammad
the scholars of islam differ on whether
or not the chapters
of the quran are something that are
passed down from the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam or was this a
an idihed or a
scholarly judgment according to the
companions of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
now here is the issue
whether or not the order of the chapters
meaning it starts with surat al fatiha
al baqarah
you know et cetera et cetera
this order of the quran beginning with
surat al-fatiha
ending with surat nes is this something
that came from the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
which ultimately means that it came from
allah directly
or is this something that was itched he
had on the part of abu bakr and umar and
the companions of the time
and they later all agreed on this order
this is a difference of opinion amongst
the scholars
however the correct opinion
is that this is something that came from
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
because when we look for any pattern
that is obvious as to how the quran was
compiled we can't really find it
it's not compiled from longest chapter
to shortest
it is roughly longest to shortest but
you'll have a very long chapter followed
by a short chapter followed by another
very long chapter
so it's not longest to shortest also we
see other parts of the quran which you
would think would go together
are separated so for example all of the
chapters of the quran
that start with alif laam meem or alif
lam
they're not all together they're
scattered throughout the quran
likewise it doesn't follow the
order that the chapters were revealed
you'll have chapters from the medany era
then you have chapters from the meccan
era and then it goes back to the medini
era and then it goes back to the
and so on and so forth so it's not
categorized that way either
nor is it categorized by
subject the the quran
it has certain subjects each chapter has
certain themes
and we see that the themes of the quran
don't seem to be the work of man in the
way that
they are organized and so when we look
at the sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
we see that any narration which
discusses him reciting multiple chapters
always comes in order so he would always
recite surat
al-allah and then
for instance or he would always recite
surat al-jumu' and surat al-munahfir
afterwards always there's never a time
when surat al-munahfir khun was recited
before
surat al-jumu' or surat
al-alah was recited after suratul
rashiya
right even times when he would speak
about the
chapters of the quran there's only one
time
to my knowledge in which the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
recited certain chapters of the quran
out of their order that is known today
where he recited surat al-baqarah
and then in nisa and then surat al-imran
he recited them in this order in the
narration of
this is the only time that i am aware of
and this was earlier
before the final revision of the quran
in the final year of the life of the
prophet
why is this important it's very
important because
it tells us that the order of the quran
is very important and this is why the
companions disliked
that anybody recite the quran backwards
that we recite it backwards now i'm not
speaking about memorization
usually in memorization people start
with the smaller chapters before the
larger chapters but it is agreed upon
that the quran should be recited
when we are reciting it to start with
surat al-fatiha
and go in the order that is in the
mushaf because this is what all of the
ummah of islam
have agreed upon we've also all agreed
that the quran should never be printed
in
any other order the quran should never
be printed
in any other order than the order of
chapters that it is
in in the time of abu bakr al-sadiq and
later in the time of uthman
so these are a few
this is kind of a prelude to
our subject and our topic tonight we'll
listen to some of the words of ibm
allah with regards to how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would behave with the quran and how he
would recite it
he says
chapter is regarding the way that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would recite the quran
the first thing he mentions is that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
had a an amount
of the quran that he would always recite
every single day and he would never miss
this is referred to as a hezek it's not
the same hizb that you find in the
must-have today
these that are in the must-have these
things came
way later the way that the companions
would recite the quran
is that if they would start a chapter
they would end it
they would never stop in the middle of a
chapter
and so what is narrated is that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
usually recite the quran
every week one time completely so he
would recite
the first day three chapters
which would be al-baqarah al-imran and
nisa the second day would be
five chapters the third day would be
seven chapters the fourth day
would be nine chapters the fifth day
would be 11 chapters
the sixth day he would recite 13
chapters
and then the seventh and final day he
would recite the rest and the remainder
of the quran
it works out to about four about
in our current mushaf today as of around
85 to 90 pages a day this is how much
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would usually recite
daily around 80 pages or so about
four and a half of our current
taji of the quran this is the way that
he would recite the quran
and this is important because
each chapter of the quran refers back to
itself
so the beginning of the chapter has to
do with the end of the chapter
and the end of the chapter is reliant on
the beginning
and so he would not if he would start a
chapter he would not
he would always end it
he says
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would recite the quran
in meticulous order and he would
recite uniquely and
clearly enunciate every
letter of the quran that he would recite
and he would always recite the quran
one verse at a time he would not recite
multiple verses without stopping at the
end of each verse
and when he would reach an elongated
letter of the quran he would elongate it
the elongated letters of the quran are
three
alif wow and these three he would
elongate
appropriately so he would
recite for instance
and he would elongate them
as we do and as we have in our common
recitation of the quran this is
taken from the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
what
[Silence]
and before reciting the quran he would
start
with seeking refuge in allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
from the cursed shaitaan
so he would say verbatim
and he took this command directly from
allah subhanahu wa
in which allah says
sometimes and this is more during the
night prayer that he would pray alone he
would recite
allah to become in a shaytan
allah i seek refuge in you from a
shaytan
minhem in himself
and he would to and he enjoyed
hearing the quran recited to him not
only he
reciting the quran but also listening to
it
recited from another and one of the
instances
is that he listened to the quran being
recited by ibn masrood he requested
that abdullah recite to him
some of the quran
and he listened to ibn masrud's
recitation of the quran in the exact
chapter
as mentioned in the sahih is surat nisa
that he listened to even
who recite the quran until he began to
his eyes began to water because he was
listening and so affected by
the recitation of ibm
and he would recite the quran in any
position that he was in
standing up sitting down
lying down he would recite the quran
he would recite the quran on wudu
and not having wudu we're speaking about
recitation of the quran from memory
but as far as touching the muslif this
is something that
we have to have for because the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam as was reported in a
sunnin
quran that no one should touch the quran
except that he be in a state of purity
and what's meant by purity here
is is that he be
pure in his clothing and that he be in a
state of wudu
the only time he would not recite the
quran
from memory is if he was in a state of
geneva
sexual impurity if he is in a state of
janabah he would not recite the quran
until he bathed
and he would also recite the quran
melodiously he would use a melody when
he would recite the quran
he would not read it any other
words would be read
rather he would read it harmoniously
and melodiously and sometimes he would
elongate
and reverberate certain letters of
the quran
as ibn mushafel
and he had reverberated the
alif in one of the one of the words of
that chapter what does this mean
this means to change the pitch of a
person's voice
as they are elongating a letter
this has been reported by imam
[Silence]
we have two narrations one narration of
mentions
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
beautify and adorn the quran with your
voices meaning to recite it melodiously
and to recite it with your best of voice
and to recite it in pitch right
and also the statement of the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam allah listens to nothing
as closely as he listens to a prophet
with a good voice who is reciting the
quran melodiously
this narration has been collected also
in a sahih
muslim so we see that
the quran is to be recited and we are to
do our best to recite it in the most
melodious most beautiful voice that we
can
muster individually
and this of course is
varies from voice to voice from person
to person
but the point of this is to add an
emotional
tone or an emotional undertone to
the logical and
ultimate truth of the wording of the
quran
allah goes
and to recite the quran melodiously and
harmoniously
is what's meant by it is two things
he says
[Silence]
he says the first understanding
of melodious recitation of the quran
is that it be recited in a way
that is not strenuous and out of
character for the reciter
for a person to strain himself
to recite in a way that is not natural
to him
this is something which is disliked by
the companions and the
self the predecessors of this ummah
rather a person is to recite the quran
to the best of his ability without
straining himself
to recite it in a way that is unnatural
to the way that his voice
naturally is
[Silence]
he says in the second understanding
that some people
took of melodious harmonious
recitation of the quran is that
the quran be recited according to
the laws and rules and
sciences of music this is something
which is impermissible
this is something which is very very
popular especially now during the last
during the last
100 years or so it's become very
popularized
that people recite the quran according
to
the different notes and keys and bars
of music and that we take the rules of
music
and apply them to the recitation of the
quran
this is also what's referred to as
this is usually done with a drum or
usually done with
a stringed instrument in order to
harmonize the voice according to the
notes
that are found on instruments this is
something which is impermissible
this is something which the companions
and the tabian
greatly disliked and would warn
people from doing this that this is
incorrect
that a person not use the laws and
ruling of music
to recite the quran whether it be the
intonation
or whether it be the actual enunciation
and pronunciation of
the words of the quran the words of the
quran are not to be stooped
to these levels
this is something which has made a huge
appearance in our final days here
as i mentioned in the last hundred years
it's been around since
the time of the tavian very sparsely
but it's become very popularized lately
because of radio and so forth and this
is all part of the prophecy
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
that he said
that he said sallallahu alaihi he will
sell them in an authentic narration
collected by imam al-bukhari in a
terrier
in which he said hastened to do good
deeds before one of six
things appear on the earth these are
signs of the hour
and he mentions that one of the
things that will occur he mentions many
things police states and
people will no longer keep ties with
their kin and so forth
he mentions as well that
one of the things that will occur near
the end of time
yet
[Silence]
that one of the signs of the hour is
that
some of the muslims will take the quran
to be
a musical instrument and something that
is
a source of entertainment rather as a
source of guidance
for what it truly is he said that a man
would become an imam
and lead prayer and be placed at the
head
and be placed to lead prayer not because
he is most
understanding nor because he is most
knowledgeable amongst the congregation
they will put him to lead them in prayer
because he
is put there to sing to them
meaning the quran it is just an
entertainment
it's not something that is taken
seriously and it's people taken
seriously
and he mentions that near the end of
time
people would use the quran for the dunya
rather than the hereafter
that people would start to use the quran
to profit
in this world rather than the hereafter
and make a living
only using the quran and writing the
coattails of the quran
this is referring to people that do not
take the quran seriously
they do not follow its commandments
rather they merely use it and use their
voices
to gain leadership positions amongst the
muslims
that is enough and sufficient for us
tonight insha allah
we have covered the way that the prophet
salallahu
we covered many things with regards to
the specifics
of the quran next week inshallah
we will be discussing a separate chapter
of the quran
with regards to how the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would visit the ill and
the sick
and how he would emphasize visitation of
those who are ill
and those who are sick from amongst the
muslims
and even visitation of non-muslims as we
will mention inshallah
muhammad we ask allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to grant us wisdom to benefit us
from what we have heard
and to make us of those who hear the
truth and have the insight to
distinguish it from falsehood and the
courage to follow it to its end
allah
be